welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation titled
considerations on the development of
quantitative lateral flow tests it's my
pleasure to introduce you to dr dominic
dekassen
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following at the end of the presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr dominic
dicasson i will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you for the kind introduction and
welcome to today's sessions
um i want to give you a quick insight on
some considerations that you have to
take or should take when developing
quantitative lateral flow essays
we will cover a variety of topics today
which
will lead from some basic principles of
lateral flow essay first as a as a quick
reminder
to differences in sandwich and
competitive tests
but also we will touch material
selection reagent selection
various manufacturing processes
but also go over to different resource
systems that are already established but
also being considered for the future
so let's just get started straight away
and look
what exactly is a lateral flow essay
so with the lateral flow device we are
talking of a system that consists of
various materials it's a multi-component
system it's very complex
and therefore especially
challenging in development and
production
nevertheless
the beauty of the system also lies in
its simplicity for the end user
because
all you need apart from the sample or
test liquid is already combined in one
device
typically the lateral flow device
consists of
four components and a plastic housing
we are talking about a sample pad
which can also be a blood separator
which takes up your samples
and prepares them by adjusting ph values
or
the viscosity for the later flow
we then transfer to a conjugate release
pad
where we capture the later detector
of
your test
and then we move to typically a
nitrocellulose membrane
which you would see in your later
application in the
open window
on this there are test and control lines
dispensed
which
change the intensity or color when the
liquid bypasses them and you achieve a
reaction
in the end we have an absorption pad
which
is also often called a wick pad which
controls the flow and keeps the sample
liquid after
the immunoassay
basically the lateral flow comes from
the liquid flowing laterally across
these
this construct containing of multiple
components
when we are talking about lateral flow
tests
we mainly have two different essay types
which are sandbridge test and a
competitive test
the sandbridge test is way more common
it's typically used in most of
lateral flow essays and some of the most
prominent
ones are pregnancy tests or also most of
the
current covet 19 letter flow assays
they're used for macromolecular analytes
which have
multiple binding sites
a minimum of two and therefore typically
are large molecules
the
analyte can be bound by your conjugate
and when passing the test line
the conjugate can also then be
captured
by a capture antibody together with the
analyte
which
is visualized in an increase in the
signal intensity
of the
test line
the control line only captures the
conjugate and therefore presents a
visual readout for a negative sample the
analyte is not present and as the
capture antibody cannot bind to the
conjugate itself you will not get a
signal
competitor tests however
work a bit different they work exactly
the opposite
they are used for very small molecules
which typically have only one binding
site
such as struck of abuse tests for
example
in a positive sample liquid
your analyte
would again bind to the conjugate
but as the
test line
consists not of a capture antibody but
typically consists of a competitor which
is very often the same as the analyte
the conjugate cannot bind to it as is
already
in in a binding state with your analyte
molecule therefore for a positive sample
you will
not get a test signal
nevertheless
for a negative sample you do not have
that analyte and your conjugate can bind
to your test line
and it's represented with an increase in
signal intensity
so for a competitive
lateral flow essay
you have a decrease in signal
with an increase in analyte
this is very
important as it also helps understand
the later
topics in this talk
if we move on with the basics we have to
decide between a qualitative test and a
quantitative test
qualitative test is
the very basics of lesser wood flow
a signal at the test line typically
indicates the presence of your analyzers
you want to capture such as for the
pregnancy test the hc hcg
in your sample liquid above a detection
limit because you need certain amounts
to give that signal
however the exact amount of your analyte
in the liquid
cannot be detected you can only say that
it is there it's basically a yes no
decision
which is represented in a visible
readout signal and can be just detected
by by the eye of the end user
a quantitative test
works a bit different
in this case a signal at the test line
does not only indicate the presence of
your analyte
above the detection limit
but it also determines how much of the
analyte is there
typically you need cannot
read it out just visually with your eyes
you need a specialized reader system
to determine
the intensity of the signal
typical examples for these applications
are cardiac markers in human blood
or mycotoxins and serials
we also
already talked about that you have a
certain limit of detection but what does
that mean a limit of detection or also
lod
is the lowest amount of an analyte in
your sample that can be detected but not
quantified
this is only a theoretical value and you
should not use your limit of detection
in your later tests in the later tests
especially for quantitative tests you
will always use the lower limit of
quantification the lloq
this is the lowest analyte concentration
a reader system can read out precisely
and repeatedly
basically the difference between a
theoretically possible value with the
lod and a value that you can apply to
the field with the loq
you also have an upper limit of
quantification because at certain
amounts your reader gets your test
system gets overwhelmed by the analyte
therefore you can also just determine
between
two points which is called your
measuring interval between the lower
limit of quantification and the upper
limit of quantification
one big aspect
is always the uncertainty of your system
it's
basically the fact that even if you
measure
a specific analyte
with the same known concentration that
you can have some standard variation
around the mean value
and the ultimate goal needs to be
always to eliminate that uncertainty to
levels that are as low as possible the
lower your uncertainty in the test
system
the better
let's look at
some of the most common challenges that
you will face as a developer for
quantitative lateral flow essays
you have to take care of multiple
components and variables
the first one is
even before just looking at
combining it to a lateral flow essay is
looking at your sample variability
what do you want to measure and how can
it change you should really know your
analyte in detail and also your
potential sample liquids
for example
human urine
has
very different behavior in its ph value
in the morning it can be very acidic
with a ph of around 5.5
but in the evening it can be alkaline up
to ph of eight
this can be within one patient and if
you change between different patients
the difference is probably even higher
the same applies to saliva where you
have different viscosities
whatever the patient did eat before
or what he did drink
as a nest test you need to decide
is your analyte accessible to a sandwich
assay so that would have multiple
binding sites or do you need to move to
a competitive essay which is typically a
bit more tricky to control as you really
need to control the conjugate release
here
always a critical choice is what
materials do you use in your lateral
flow essay for sample pads wick pads
conjugate pads but also for the membrane
especially for the membrane
you have to consider what the influence
of these is on your test do you use a
slow membrane
where you have a high
time for your analyte added test and
control line or do you use a fast
membrane do you need
thick or thin wicking pads to speed up
the flow and store liquid do you need to
separate blood at the start of the test
a very complex topic which we could talk
hours about
the next thing you need to
take a look at
is your reagents what are you using are
you working with antibodies are they
polyclonal or anti-air monoclonal are
you using alpha mass optimus heptines
for all of these they have all have
different
properties
however
some
criteria always apply to them they need
to be clean they need to be
reproducible
and they need to have the right binding
kinetics
if you now have your test system settled
down from the materials reagents and
analyte set you should look at
manufacturing which we will do later on
as well
what are the most critical processes
for your manufacturing
because these can affect the
[Music]
outcome of the lateral flow test
and in the end we will take a look at
various reader systems today as well
what can you do
with the readers what are pros and cons
of various readers
we'll cover that later
story short of all these tasks of
for you as a developer is
that your ultimate goal is to minimize
the uncertainty of your measurement as
far as possible because lower your
uncertainty is the more precise your
quantitation can be
if we look at the difference
for a readout between sandwich and
competitive tests
we see certain differences as i
described earlier
a sandwich test works with an increase
in signal intensity over the analyte
concentration
it is typically a sigmoidal curve
which gives you various windows of
operation you have a lower detection
limit which is a set just to be used
theoretically
but you also have your measurement area
between the lower limit and the upper
limit of quantification which is
typically a more or less linear
linear area and the flatter the linear
part of this curve is the wider is the
range of concentration that you can
cover with your test signal system
if you however move to two high analyte
concentrations you see a decrease
in the reader signal again
this is the so-called hook effect
basically you have too much analyte for
your conjugate
and you start binding
unmarked or unconjugated analyte to your
test line and therefore you have a
decrease in your reader signal so make
sure that you always work between your
lower and your upper limit of
quantification for your analyte
if we look at competitive tests we see
already that it works exactly the
opposite
we have a decrease in signal
with an increase in analyte
concentration once again a sigmoidal
curve distribution
and the steepness of the curve
um
also again determines the concentration
range that you can cover with your test
system make sure to always work between
your lower and upper limit of
quantification
and if you see an effect of
signal at very high analyte
concentrations it is typically
non-specific binding of the detector
but you can just mathematically in your
re-dot software
get rid of that
let's come to
material selection
we're talking typically or mainly about
membranes and papers but for
some tests we are also talking about
glass fibers
all of these materials are typically
squamous random structures especially
the membranes they are mainly defined by
thickness and capillary flow time
and the capillary flow time represents
how fast your test moves through the
membrane or also your test system
papers
such as cellulose papers or also the
glass fibers are mainly used for the
wick pad and conjugate as well as sample
preparation pen they are often soaked in
buffer
you do this to adjust for ph value
viscosity salt concentrations
or as mentioned to purify blood plasma
you need to optimize your buffer
composition
always to the lowest required
concentration at the thin end of the
paper specification because your paper
will always have very inner thickness
you
you typically have like a 20 range rough
for example and always optimized for the
thin end of the specification because
otherwise you will have a oversaturated
system
when you are modifying or soaking your
conjugate pads with a conjugate solution
you should never soak them for a
quantitative test the reason
for that is once again the thickness
variation in your conjugate pads
if you soak a material
you
cannot control how much corn you get you
deposit on it you should rather
dispense your conjugate pad with high
precision equipment to guarantee that
always the same
amount of conjugate is present and
therefore your test is controlled
for the membranes you typically need to
block them to avoid unspecific binding
of analytes or detectors to the membrane
metric
the good and bad thing about
nitrocellulose is that it binds proteins
but you only want to bind it at your
test and control line
therefore you can use various blocking
approaches one of the most commons
the block on the slide
is not recommended to be used for
quantitative essays
the problem with that is that the block
on the fly typically is carried out
while running the test itself but you
also get a
concentration gradient
by running your blocking agent
and this makes the test unreliable we
recommend that you use an additional
manufacturing step
for blocking the membrane in a
controlled manner
okay and one thing that you always need
to be
aware of is that the
reaction time of the reagents at the
test line is very very short
that's why you should test your membrane
for the upper and lower specification
end of the capillary flow time
you can do that by asking your material
supplier for limiting samples which are
basically at the edge of the
specification
but it might happen that you also need
to work with a customized membrane
if we look at the membranes a bit more
in detail
and especially at the capillary rise
time we see that it has a high effect on
your test itself
we typically work
a set in specification ranges
and
ideally
your reagents would be compatible with a
full membrane specification
unfortunately this is not often the case
if you use for example a membrane that
is too slow there's a high chance of
false positive signals because your
reagent maintains at
the test line
too long and you typically get very high
background sickness
for very fast membranes you have the
opposite your agent is not long enough
at the test line to bind
to to the conjugate and to the detector
and
therefore you get false negative results
so you really need to balance out the
speed of your membrane
um
in rare cases you have issues with both
specification edges
and that's where the challenge begins
and you need to talk about customization
if we look at various reagents that you
need for your tests
first you have to look at your antibody
and the
system which can also be abdominals
affirmations monoclonal polyclonal
antibodies
and it's essential that you have a
consistent quality of these it is
recommended that you test every batch
for its kinetic properties
basically the binding on rate 2c binder
but also the off rate
when you
lose signal again
and
preferably you should use surface
plasmon resonance but you can
also work with other
methods
for these reagents especially if you
consider going into manufacturing
scalability and reproducibility are key
in a competitive test in addition
the control line signal is often used to
calculate the reader output
you
need to consider generating standard
curves for every batch of
your
proteins of your antibodies
this is done
as by including the control line signal
into your calculation you can mitigate
batch to batch variations
so you need to make sure that you
install
sufficient quality control
procedures
as well for the antibodies as well as
for test line reagents and detectors
furthermore in a competitive test the
affinity of the detector to the target
bound at the test line
is typically different from the affinity
to the free antigen
even if the detector and the antigen are
very similar in its structure or even
the same
you should test the kinetic parameters
for both
so that you can make sure
how your binding reaction and your test
will behave
let's look at different manufacturing
processes that are essential for
your test system
what you typically do first is the
conjugation of your materials but we
will also look at lamination dispensing
and drying now
the conjugation of material really
depends on the test system that you use
it needs to be absolutely reproducible
to
minimize the uncertainty of your test
and
both the detector conjugate as well as
the test line conjugate needs to be
developed and established in a way
together with your quality control that
the quantitative number of binding per
molecules
can be determined
you can do that for example by mass
spectroscopy spectrometry
but it is key to understand your system
because the lack of reproducibility of
your conjugation process
will lead to
a higher uncertainty and therefore
not wrong signal but
not the right result in your test
and what we see in the field is that
this is really a major reason for an
increase in uncertainty
so make sure that you have your process
in control for conjugation
it
typically it also is that you need to be
providing standard curves for
your readers
with every new lot of conjugate to
remove variability
if we move further on to lamination
the lamination is
bringing all your membranes and the pads
sample pad wick pack conjugation pad
to
a
support cut you basically laminate them
on there and make sure that they are in
the right position let's say the flow
can be consistent and your material is
produced in a way
as design
however the challenge in this is the
material overlap as we are talking of
only
one or two millimeters of material
overlap
it is hard to establish that in
manufacturing environment especially as
the materials
can vary a bit they are not 100 the same
as we're talking always about
specification ranges
um for small
test numbers
many
people many companies go for manual
lamination processes however these are
not very reproducible you will get a lot
of variation in your material overlap
and therefore also a lot of uncertainty
in your quantitative test essays
therefore it is highly recommended to
use an automated lamination system
with a built-in
control and positioning
of your various test components
the dispensing of your test and control
line but also of your conjugate
is where your actual test result gets
visible so this is the the error that
you will see straight away
it is essential that you control the
dispensing
and that
you filter your dispensing solutions
prior to use because you do not want to
have any dispensing artifacts on there
make sure to control your environmental
conditions especially humidity
when dispensing onto your membrane for
example
and always align your dispensing
parameters with the thickness
variability of the membrane if you're
working with a very thick membrane
you need to
properly use more dispensing liquids
than your work with a very thin membrane
one thing that is always
to mention is
take care of your equipment
change dispensing equipment
as early as possible do preventive
maintenance
because
every error that you do here you will
see straight away in the market
the last aspect that we will handle
today is the drying process it looks
like a very simple process but
it is very challenging and very tough
you can make a lot of things right but
also a lot of things wrong here
the drying applies to
everything in your
test system it is for pads after coating
it is for trying to conjugate
for testing control lines but also for
drying the membrane after blocking
and
you should standardize your drying
processes
standardize your temperature standardize
your times and standardize your
remaining humidity
if possible use forced air convection
and do not dry
just at the air
a it takes very long to dry at superior
but you also get drying artifacts where
your sample does not dry homogeneously
which is not good for your competitive
essay
okay
let's
also now take a quick look at what
readers are out there and available
there's a lot of commercially available
equipment on the market
with
almost all kinds of possible detectors
you can target for an optical readout of
your test you can go for fluorescence
readouts up converting phosphors
magnetic readouts electrical readouts so
really a wide variety from
well-established brands on the market
however
every lattleflow essay system is to some
extent unique
and if you really want to optimize and
remove your uncertainty
you should consider talking to your
reader supplier
to customize your readers
you can
customize it for your test system
but
this can be
that you need to work at different
wavelengths that you
need to install a second camera for
detection or even just a better cassette
insertion
but you
may also have to just run an optimized
software
where you can apply your batch specific
standard curves which remove
batch to batch variation for example for
the conjugates as discussed earlier
there are various reader also in
development and one of the most
prominent developments these days is the
use of mobile phone apps
i think this is a challenge that is not
completely solved yet but it's very
promising and would make the access to
lateral flow essays
even wider in the market
it's fair to say it's a critical
solution at the moment
because it works only for visible
detectors such as gold or latex
but the biggest problem in this case is
not the letbut flow essay it's the user
of the mobile phone you have to consider
different lightning different angles
different types of cameras
so there's no standardization
in these mobile phone readout apps which
once again increases your uncertainty in
the test so your test
needs to be even better
than if you work with a customized
reader
we will see what future holds
but this is a interesting topic to to
keep an eye on
let's come to the end of this talk today
quantitative test test essays are
like the champions league of
lateral flow essays they require much
more detailed development and validation
effort
than qualitative tests
it may make sense to look for customized
materials especially membranes and pets
and to invest in elaborated quality
control processes to remove the
uncertainty of your test system
we always recommend to develop in
collaboration with your material and
reagent suppliers this comes down both
to
your antibodies to your conjugates to
your membrane
and always keep in mind the ultimate
goal needs to be to remove the
uncertainty of your test system with
that i want to thank you for your
intention and we are open for questions
now
thank you dr dekasten for that
outstanding presentation we will now
move into the live q and a portion of
the presentation as a reminder please
submit your questions via the q a box
okay and we're getting a lot of
questions in already um
dominique our first question is
what are the advantages and
disadvantages of including control line
signals in the calculation of analyte
concentrations
okay
as discussed earlier you can have
variation in your conjugate but you can
also have variation in your on off rate
for the binding kinetics of your
analytes
by including the control line signal in
the calculation of your analyte
concentration by the readout
you can mitigate this batch to batch
variability to some extent
you can feed your detector
your readout system with this
information and compensate for these
variabilities
of the conjugate release due to the
sample liquid due to pad variability
but also due to overlap inconsistencies
from test strip to test strip
remove the uncertainty and bring it to a
more precise result of your readout
thank you for that
our next question
i want to detect a pentapeptide and
nasal liquid and conjugated the peptide
via the only amino group it contains to
bsa as a carrier for immunization and
antibody generation
the antibodies generated react very well
with the bsa peptide on the test line
but i cannot get any competition with
the free peptide in the sample what can
i do
this is a very specific question but
also a very good one
you always have to consider that if you
bring your
peptide
into
into a system
that they can behave very different
i would say that
the most likely option for this is that
your peptide that you want to detect
will be positively charged in the sample
liquid
which is typical for nasal nasal liquids
however in the conjugation process
because you play a lot of with the ph
values this charge can be consumed
and the antibody that you
basically
multiplied
is therefore specific for the uncharged
molecule
you should try to
force the sample liquid to a ph between
nine and ten
and therefore deprotonate the freehand
and make it look like the one bound to
to your test line
um
this is a very simple but
also very accessible approach as you can
achieve this by coating your sample pad
as described earlier
with with a different buffer to bring
your test liquid to the desired ph value
and
yeah
i would be highly interested if you
could let us know afterwards if this
worked
thank you for that we are definitely
getting some fantastic questions from
the audience and hopefully they'll be
able to follow up there with you
for our third question
i would like to detect very small
differences between targets that have
identical base structures
is there a type of detector molecule
that you can recommend and why
this is
also once again challenging
it depends on the exact target and its
binding sites
if we're talking about
very very small difference between a
molecule
like a single
alcohol
function single amine function in
cyclic system like cholesterol for
example
this is really a nightmare to control
the only system i would see capable of
resolving this
is an optimal based
detector system because
these can be highly functional
synthesized they are artificial and
therefore you have the highest control
about their binding properties
um i do not see you being able to
control that with antibodies because
they are not specific enough for your
binding site
therefore i would go without the mess
thank you dr dekassen for your wonderful
insight we have time for one more
question
what options are there for the qc of
specific reagents
with reagents i assume that you go for
binders and conjugates and not materials
such as membranes or pets
binders such as antibodies optimus alpha
mass
i would always check for their purity
you can use
sds page you can use an active system or
similar
and you should test them for their on
and off rates in the kinetic binding
properties
by surface plasmon resonance preferred
if you have that um your conjugates for
example haptens with a carrier protein
or similar
again check them for purity
but also check them for the number of
haptens bound per carrier protein you
can achieve that by using mass
spectrometry
so make sure that
especially your purity of the reagent
is spot on and then you're in a good way
okay we're out of time for today
unfortunately but don't worry any
questions that were submitted and not
answered today by our speaker will be
addressed via email thank you again dr
dekassen and thank you to the audience
for your outstanding questions
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months please
remember to share it with colleagues who
might be interested in today's topic and
don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
thank you again dr dekassen and until
next time goodbye everyone
thank you bye